america has only 4.4 of world's
population only 4.4 percent
yet 31 of all opioid
that deaths that we have around the
world is from us
[Music]
my guest today is dr chris johnson who
is an expert speaker on the opioid
crisis public health advocate author
emergency physician
and every week we talk about who we want
to bring up to interview on what topic
this opioid topic came up you know
oxycodone and many of us have either had
direct experience with it or an indirect
experience with it a loss of a loved one
it's very painful
but one of the statistics i someone
there's many different things we're
going to get into one of the statistics
i saw him talk about was the fact that
america has only 4.4 percent of world's
population only 4.4 percent
yet 31 of all opioid that deaths that we
have around the world is from us so we
want to find out why is us this is not a
statistic we want to be leading in and
he's the expert in this area so dr chris
johnson thank you so much for making the
time for being a guest on valuetainment
well thank you for inviting me i
appreciate it
yeah i mean that talk you gave uh on
tedx ted talks was what you had you
obviously you have a charisma you have
charm but the statistics i was looking
i'm like you got to be kidding me why
are we not talking about this so would
you mind taking a moment and telling the
audience your background obviously i
have it here you garnered the first a
physician award in 2017. you you've
spoken to fda advisory committees you've
spoken to a bunch of different groups
but give us your history and what got
you to be wanting to do more research on
this specific topic
well um as you mentioned my background
is emergency medicine and i'm a
practitioner uh here in the twin cities
in minnesota
and
it might be a little bit unusual that
some would find like why is an emergency
medicine physician talking about this
shouldn't we be talking to a pain
physician or we should we be talking to
addiction physicians and there certainly
are experts in that in that area too
but the what got me motivated to learn
more about this
was my own clinical practice in the
early to mid 2000s
where
i was going to work every day
and
i found that i really couldn't get
through a shift
without seeing
a patient who was either having some
sort of
pain exacerbation or complication from
opioids um
maybe someone overdosing they needed me
to give them either like narcan the
antidote sometimes i'd have to intubate
them put them on a ventilator but
actually more often than not it was
someone on high dose opioids such as
oxycontin plus percocet another opiate
is short acting for a breakthrough
and they were coming in because they
were having breakthrough pain they were
out of their opioids and i was looking
around like why is this happening i
don't remember this
in my medical school training i don't
remember this when i was training is
what's called a resident physician which
is an apprentice physician
but it's happening every shift now and
i try to invest like why is this has it
always been like this or is this
something you're asking people at that
time are you like that i'm asking myself
i mean for the most part i'll be honest
most people like they're just like oh i
guess this is what's happening this is
how we're going to practice now and you
just manage it
pretty wild and and
you know who knew how that happened but
i i sort of took it the next step and i
and i investigated
is this is this different or is it just
i've just been unaware and only becoming
aware of something that's been going on
for years and years
and what i found was that it was in fact
very different that that
in 1995 the united states was not like
this
um
yes you still had problems with opioid
addiction you still had even opioid
overdose deaths okay
but
the country dramatically changed from
1995 to 2005.
the prescriptions for opioids massively
increased and with the massive increase
in the prescriptions you had all this
all these patients who now became
dependent or had chronic opioid chronic
pain on chronic opioids and they were
having problems with it um
and so my research at that time was
mostly to investigate is this real is
what i am seeing real um
and how did it happen and so that became
my motivation um mostly to see like what
i was what i was seeing every day was
not
was not corresponding to what i was
taught as a as a physician in training
that is these medicines were effective
they were safe and they had very low
abuse potential um and that that wasn't
what i was seeing every day
yeah what i did is when you started
talking i said okay these stats they
they don't make any sense to be the
staggering so i went to drugabuse.gov
drugabuse.gov and this is the stat that
came up this is as recent as 2019
national drug overdose deaths involving
any opioids
number of among all ages gender 99 to
2019. great so in 1999 it's less than 10
000 okay
then we go to 21 000 in 2010 but then
the dramatic upswing to 49 860. and by
the way this is pre-covered so we can't
say well during covet people are sitting
around there and there are a lot of
different pain
this this sudden ex i mean this is not a
small trend here
some people would say this is even at a
faster growth than the s p 500 not some
people would say it's accurate so what
caused this level of growth in americans
taking opioids
well actually that and that graph is out
of date if it included the year 2020
that number from 50 000 or just about 50
000 overdose deaths from opioids would
be 70 000. holy moly
so while covet happened all right the
opioid epidemic
got much worse
okay
and so
even that graph as as dramatic as it is
is out of date and it's even worse now
um
and if if it went back farther from 1999
if it went back to like 1992 there were
only about 6 000 deaths per year
and about 4 000 were from prescription
another 2 000 from heroin and that had
been stable going back into the 80s and
even the 70s and then starting in the
late 1990s early 2000s you saw it go up
and up and up and that corresponds
to when the treatment for chronic pain
changed and we started prescribing
opioids for back pain for headaches for
arthritis
and we exposed this this massive new
group in the patient population to
opioids
and caused a great many to become
dependent or addicted at that time uh
and then
as we started to
realize in the 2010s around 2010 2015
that prescriptions were the root cause
of this uh increase in dependence and
addiction and death we started to level
off the prescribing but it was too late
by then you had you had already created
this population of people who now needed
this
and as their dependents got worse as
their addiction got worse then they
turned to things like heroin so that's
starting around the 2015 you see the
heroin go up yep
and then
starting in the like 2017
then you have the fentanyl come in and
when
you have this population that's
dependent and now they are getting
uh you know
you know fentanyl from china and other
places that have learned to manufacture
this stuff and they ship it and then
people who are uh who are selling uh on
the on the uh not the medical market but
the extra legal market to these patients
who have become dependent from what we
did
that's where you have this explosion in
overdose deaths because
when they go outside the regular medical
marketplace you don't know what's in it
and that's when you get people might
find they may think they're buying
oxycodone pills but they're actually
oxycodone pills and there's fentanyl in
there um but they didn't that's that's
the danger so that's why you have that
dramatic increase even in the last five
to eight years of deaths is because
that's where it's coming from it's
coming from the heroin and the illicit
fentanyl
yeah so how come how come we're not i
mean look i saw the j and j
uh lawsuit that took place i think
started in 2019 uh uh 2020 october 13th
and then july 21st uh drug distributors
and j j reached 26 billion dollar deal
to end opioids lawsuits
do are you seeing a major progress being
made by both doctors because you you
give credit to four reasons why this is
taking place right it wasn't just let's
blame the pharmaceutical companies it
was four different things that you
talked about are you seeing this being
an issue that the folks at the top from
the politics or whoever holds them
accountable is bringing this up more are
they kind of looking the other way from
your experience
my experience is that um these
settlements that you're talking about
and if you look closely at the
settlements you'll see that how many
years that they're paid out over
and it's often times seven years
sometimes ten years
that they are making these you know
these restitution payments okay
but understand that they've made
billions and billions on their on their
drugs and they will continue to sell and
make billions while they're making these
payments so it's really just a yes the
number sounds big and you might say
what's better than nothing
but
it's a good business model i mean no
executives went to jail and none are
going to jail you know and the sacklers
the ones who owned purdue pharma they
just got a bankruptcy settlement and
said earlier this month
they they are immune to civil litigation
for in perpetuity now they're there and
they get to keep over
there many billions they've made they
get to keep all that and they never
admitted wrongdoing so
fines seems to be what pharmaceutical
companies do and is seen as the cost of
doing business and
it's a good business decision if you're
a pharmaceutical company or if you're a
board or a shareholder like yes you
market these drugs they're not really
approved for what you say they're using
but we're making a lot of money
eventually someone will impose a fee but
it'll be far less than than than what
we've made so that's that's a that's a
good business decision and what i want
to point out to you and some of your
viewers is that this is not the first
time that has happened
other drugs have had similarly been
marketed off label
and i'm referring to a drug called
neurontin here it's just a very famous
case
neurontin was marketed by pfizer as a a
drug for seizure disorder if the other
medicines weren't controlling it but
then it got off label marketed for
everything from headaches to adhd um
and because of that it got so over
prescribed and made billions um
and they had to pay fine subsequently as
well uh several hundred million dollars
but if you paying 700 million dollars on
a drug you made billions uh per year
that is a good business model you pay
the fine no executives go to jail the
shareholders are happy the only people
that get harmed are the patients so
uh yeah so i'm looking at this you said
the arrangement you're right under this
agreement the country's three
distributors would make payments of 21
billion over 18 years johnson and
johnson would pay 5 billion over 9 years
so it's chump change uh to these guys
and but can you go back to the input in
perpetuity which means there is no lack
of accountability can you unpack what
that means
uh when they say it's in perpetuity so
if something happens if you can unpack
that for the rest of us what that means
is that according to
all right and i i am not a i can't i
can't claim to be a bankruptcy legal
expert okay
but according to the stories i have read
about the bankruptcy filing in the state
of new york for purdue pharma the
sacklers have been absolved of
wrongdoing and they may not be held
accountable
for any future civil litigation due to
the harm of their product that they
cause through exposing them even
irresponsibly um
and remember if purdue pharma had to pay
had to pay hundreds of millions back in
like 2007
for irresponsible marketing of their
product even then so this is there's
nothing new about the irresponsible
marketing they've and then they they
basically they got away with it
so but here's so that's what it means is
that how can they do that though who
allows them to do that are these
politicians who are helping them do that
who allows these contracts to be written
in a way where they're protected
it has to do with the how the bankruptcy
laws are written and they are written
true by politicians but but remember
that politicians are writing these laws
that are often made put together by the
lobbyists that represent the corporate
business interests so they make the laws
very favorable
to the business interests sure sure and
so that then you then you can now you've
got the law in the books and you're like
hey we'd like to do something but this
you know we can't because here's how
it's written now and i'm like yeah
just out of curiosity wasn't the vaccine
also written the same way as well in
perpetuity that if something were to
happen there can't be a level of
accountability to j and j and pfizer
about what the vaccine oh
i'll be honest i i don't know i can't
say i don't know how that was i saw that
where there's a similar uh
accountability where
you know if something were to happen say
something there's a reaction they can't
be held accountable either it protects
them but i want to go to this one side
that gives hats on what else is going on
with opioids um
here's uh mass.gov
uh four out of five people who use
heroin began by misusing prescription
pain medications uh similar ones you're
talking about oxycontin vicodin fuelly
commonly just prescribed pain
medications
1 in 14 reports they've misused or
abused a prescription drug at least once
i was asking my peers here right now
before we setting up the camera i said
how many guys have lost a friend to
opioids everybody raised their hand one
of them was a teenager because she just
got her hands on i said was it from the
doctor or somebody else no it was just a
teenager one of her friends gave it to
she thought it was something else she
took it boom uh she lost her life two
out of two out of three teens abusing
prescription meds say they get them from
family or friends so i'll give you one
story of a friend of mine and this is
very close to me
best friend of mine when i was in l.a
going to glendale high school
he uh uh
uh you know started taking vicodin
and he was getting this vicodin from a
dentist that was selling it to him and
it was selling it for whatever the price
was he started off with one you know
he's having pain he's like man i'm
really having this pain it went to two
to five it got to a point it was taking
10 20 a day vicodin's obviously we ended
up losing him uh years ago and i took
him to rehab and it wasn't a good
situation i remember one time we're at a
uh a restaurant and he steps out right
after we were done with bible study on
friday now i'm trying to get this guy to
kind of try to figure out a way to
change he goes to his car
pulls into his car and i sneak up on him
to see where he's at because i knew when
he would roll his uh when he would talk
and i see he pulls in to take the
vicodin and i take it out of his hand i
take the pills
i've never heard anybody beg for
anything in my life to give to them
never i've never heard anyone be this
weak to beg to say please give it to me
i have so much pain
can you unpack the level of
how addictive these opioids are when
somebody starts so walk me through
what the process is and where it goes
next so hey typically it's a doctor
gives it to them walk me through the
process this is your world that you
research what does that really look like
well what i would i want to maybe back
up just a little bit here okay what it
what is certainly true is that um
three out of four people who who
three to four four to five seventy five
to eighty percent that's about roughly
like who move on to heroin began
uh their use of opiates with a
prescription
and
uh and i would i would also like maybe
quantify or push back a little bit on
misuse
what happens with opioids is that
these are pharma pharmaceutical
these molecules mimic the own opioids we
make okay we have receptors for these
okay but our brains are built for
physiologic doses small ones
and then we're getting pharmaceutical
doses big ones okay
and the brain naturally pushes back the
brain doesn't want to feel elation and
euphoria all the time
it pushes back almost immediately and
says this is not normal
and what we know is that very quickly
when you start exposing yourself to
opioids is your brain starts to change
and it stops responding to them and it
actually develops these processes called
opponent processes where they don't work
so well and there was a very important
study done in 2016 by the kaiser
foundation in the washington post that
shows people who are exposed to opioids
report becoming dependent or addicted in
as little as two months that's how fast
it works
so it's not so much that they are
misusing them
what they're finding is that they are
being told they work for pain and then
very quickly find out well one isn't
working for pain anymore now i need two
for pain now i need five for pain and so
less it can be better character this is
natural
physiologic homeostasis and what
homeostasis means in medicine biology is
that the body wants stability
so
these medicines are are not working like
they were supposed to because the body
is pushing back and so that's what
happens when a person again like your
friends get starts it out for tooth pain
and one was fine now they need three
and it hijacks the brain's own opioid
system your own reward system gets
hijacked by these chemicals
such that now
you make almost no opioid yourself your
endorphins with your natural opioids
stop getting made the brain is pushing
back on their effect and so now when you
are without them
your brain says i feel awful do
something
and so that might have led to that
episode where your friend is begging
because they were in in pure
misery
because the molecule that everyone sort
of almost takes for granted you've got a
regular amount of it keeping you feeling
normal that that feeling of normal is
gone
and that's how dangerous and how how
destructive they can be that in as
little as two months
you can change the brain enough to
become dependent
yeah
would you say the closest thing to if we
were to make a reference not closest
thing to how addictive it is but is it
kind of like uh when a bodybuilder or
somebody does steroids and their
testosterone they're no longer producing
testosterone naturally and they stay on
it for one month two months three months
let's just say they cycle they go six
months 12 months
and the body when they get off of it the
skin gets yellow the body doesn't know
how to produce testosterone would that
be a
similar way to look at where your body
forgot how to produce that testosterone
yeah i think that's actually that's a
very good sort of analogy
you might say that sort of a bodybuilder
let's say a male bodybuilder in
particular um
you know this sort of now i'm not a
i like fitness i do fitness but i'm not
a bodybuilder um
and i've never done testosterone but
since your testicles make testosterone
what bodybuilders find is that the more
they get testosterone through a shot you
know from out from their environment
the testicles shrink okay and that's
just the body's natural response okay
why would i bother making all my own
testosterone i'm getting it from the
environment we're going to shut this
down and so yes that is exactly the same
mechanism the body realizes it's getting
this compound it doesn't need to make it
so it stops
who is the most powerful person
that is bringing this up and wanting to
do something about it if you were to
name a couple people when i mean
powerful i mean somebody that can really
move
uh oh you know that can do something
about it
huh
president governor senators
i mean we've we've got you know we've
had um
you know the government governor uh of
minnesota um
put together this pain pill problem
summit back in 2015 the state of
minnesota uh is actually involved in a
in a very important effort to bring
physician prescribing under control i
work for the department of human
services opioid prescribing work group
and we're actually
now reviewing prescriptions by doctors
all over the state and giving them
feedback for the first time ever i mean
even i'm getting feedback like i never
knew
how much i was prescribing relative to
my other emergency medicine doctors now
i get a report card every year that
shows how many am i prescribing what are
my peers prescribing
um
so that's a very powerful effort that is
being led by the state of minnesota i
don't know if it's being done in other
states um
you know i i can't say that i know
anyone who's really bringing
the medical industry to heal it's sort
of it you know or or to to to control it
it's sort of being left on its own to
try and regulate itself and and
self-regulation i doesn't have a great
track record uh in this country whether
it's medicine or banking um
you know part of the problem part of the
problem is that if you'll look up at the
top five
lobbying contributors in this in this
country it's the american medical
association the american hospital
association and pharma are in the top
five each and every year i've seen that
and
as a consequence some of the changes
that we might want to see to make
medicine more more uh responsible such
as um
let's interrupt the financial
relationships between pharmaceutical
companies and doctors let's stop having
you know just regular fee for service
payment that just encourages chronic
consumption of health care
these things that might um
reduce the the sort of business
incentive just to keep the process going
in medicine none of that is really
happening as far as i can tell
um
not that senators aren't worried about
it we have multiple senators and
congress people who know friends that no
family have had problems
but in terms of changing the overall
marketplace i can't say that i've seen
anything why why do you think i mean
look i'm looking at right now johnston
johnson they've said they uh suspended
supporting any political donations in
2021 but if i go and look at their 2019
and 2020 2019 they gave lobbyists
uh uh
5.83 million dollars in 2020 was 5.57
million dollars at the top is biden 370
second is trump 106. so they gave four
times more to biden than trump then it's
dnc services court democratic senatorial
republican senatorial so it's not like
it's it's a
four red it is
six blue that they're giving money to if
we were to say which side politically
they're supporting um and this is public
info people can't find this kind of
stuff but look you're here when i would
say this like if you look at the i mean
remember that that top five list you
know you uh uh including those that goes
back year after year whoever is in power
all right
i'm aware of this
a gift to both sides they have an
incentive to make sure that whoever i
wonder who they give to moore because of
why i wonder if they give right more if
they give left more i don't know if
you've ever investigated this because
i think there has to be a reason why
nobody in power is bringing this up why
i mean look we can sit there and uh when
there's a presidential uh
person that's running say governor's
running they typically campaign around
something so we're gonna camp obama
around obamacare okay fine that's what
he's campaigning grant jimmy carter
human rights fine
you got oil you got immigration you got
wall you got
drugs you got fight against drugs you
got
how come we're not if we're talking 70
000 right you're saying 70 000 in 2020
statistics came out that out of the 660
something thousand people this was
public info out of 661 000 people that
died from covid
5 died with kobet being the leading
indicator so five percent of 660 you're
talking about 33 000 people died as a
leading cause being coveted you're
talking 70 000 died last year leading
cause in opioids
how come no one's calling the alarm how
come i don't see it on cnn fox msnbc
wise is are they afraid of bringing it
up or is everybody kind of like hush
hush because they're giving us money for
campaigns and commercials well there i
mean i mean some have been doing uh
documentaries on this i think there was
the forgotten epidemic i forget if it
was cnn or msnbc but understand that
when you have privately fund campaigns
that are routinely in the millions tens
of millions maybe hundreds of millions
um
these are largely privately funded they
mean whether you're right or whether
you're left you are often getting
corporate donations or corporate
interest group donations
and
when you have when you take someone's
money it's very difficult to tell them
no or to act contrary to their interest
and these major donors give to both
sides so that whoever ends up in power
they don't mess
where they don't mess with those the
health care system which right now is
very lucrative and as you probably know
um the united states healthcare industry
is over three trillion dollars a year um
by itself that's the fifth largest
economy in the in the world just just
healthcare and what you also might know
is that
we live about the same number of years
as they do in greece
and they spend a third of that
per person
so it's not like the the patient in the
united states is actually getting a good
return on on the cost so
we have a very expensive system that is
not giving us life expectancy in return
and we have a political system that is
often dependent on private donations and
so who when they make their whichever
side gets the money they don't mess with
this system
and there are many calling for reform i
think it was a john mccain who called
for campaign finance reform as well um
sort of getting the money out of
campaigns would then make candidates
more responsive to the needs of a
population as opposed to the needs of
you know corporate imperatives
yeah so so how much deeper are you going
with this i'm curious because
uh uh uh are you uh are you going
surface level was like look here's
what's going on
let's have somebody else go and figure
out a way to address this are you
somebody that's saying here's what's
going on and you're making the phone
call and you're setting up the meetings
to present this to the decision makers
to the guys can we do something about
this this is real how deep are you going
with this issue i'm curious
um
i'm going as deep as i possibly can
i would i would say that um in my role
for the minnesota department of human
services and and and and
being part of that effort as far as our
legislation to bring better prescribing
um
i am taking that to as high as i can on
that level now
do i have the ear of you know leaders
and decision makers here
i probably don't
um
i make it a point to attend the
conferences and when i see people from
the dea come and speak uh and i have
meetings occasionally with people like
representative angie craig
believe me i believe me i try um
but but i i i can't say that i have the
ear of the of those kind of decision
makers though i am open to any and all
anyone who will listen i will speak to
yeah i mean i just think so
it's fair to say these numbers are not
fake right so i mean if the government's
giving us the stats
you're looking at 70 000 people and in
1999 it was 10 000 people okay so if we
go from 10 to 70 000
and everybody has a story there so it's
a it's a level drug below heroin
and we all know what happens when a
person gets heroin i i had a person that
told me it's tougher to get off a
vicodin than it is to get off of heroin
you know it's always been heroin is
what's tougher to get off of
historically it's always been heroin and
stuff to get off of instead of
vicodin
how hard is it for somebody once once
they're in too deep to get off of the
addiction they have to the opioid
um
it is very hard um i guess i don't have
the stats on how long it would take
this opioid versus that opioid um
we do have treatment for opioid
addiction which i talked about um
uh i mean i don't know if i could get
into it much in my ted talk i was only
had i had like 18 minutes um but the but
medical assisted therapy that's the
methadone that's the buprenorphine
we know that those treatments are
available for people who have opioid
dependence opiate addiction um
but understand that um it doesn't get it
doesn't make things whole again they
don't get rid of the changed neural
pathways they reduce the cravings
so that the people aren't miserable but
the but the physiologic and the
neurophysiologic changes of addiction
persist um the study that i quote often
to people who are trying to get off
those drugs is that methadone and
buprenorphine reduce your risk by about
a third to a half
in the first year okay
that's significant but it's not nothing
you're the risk of an overdose is still
very high
and if you look at all cause mortality
not just overdose deaths but all cause
mortality the risk of death if you
develop use disorder even getting
treatment is about one in five in ten
years
one in five in ten years because people
who have developed addiction
also develop higher rates of
cardiovascular disease they get higher
rates of cancer they get higher rates of
hepatitis
those also are can be very dangerous so
addiction is not just overdose all the
dangerous life things that happen to you
when you're in the midst of addiction
happen to you at a higher rate too
um
i want to go back at least one thing to
say about like getting the ear of
decision makers um
what i would what i would also say to
you and i think i sent you the the
the information is that
even the american medical association is
compromised by relationships with the
pharmaceutical industry
at their board of trustees meeting in
2019 and i i brought up their meeting
minutes and i sent them along
the american medical association the
loudest voice of doctors
is partners with malincroft they're
partners with teva they're partners with
pharma um
so when i you try to have you know you
you try to have a loud voice and reach
our politicians and decision makers
understand there's nothing i'm going to
do that's going to have a louder voice
than the president of the ama
but the ama is compromised by
relationships with pharma which makes
the independent voice of protest
difficult to be heard
do you trust the ama
no
do you trust cdc
i don't think the cdc is compromised by
financial conflicts of interest the way
that ama is but i i don't um
i i can't say i've looked at their
meeting ministers
if you i can pull it up right now who
funds cdc and you'd be shocked by who
funds a
uh cdc and world health organization so
so so you you don't trust them because
you think they're compromised by big
pharma
i i would say that you know when you see
that on they have something called a
corporate roundtable and teva is there
malinkrat's there pharma is there all
these pharmaceutical companies are there
um
that is why you've never actually seen
the ama the american medical association
come out with a statement you know say
as early as 2010 saying
you know in looking at the at the at the
record we do not see that opioids are
providing the benefit of long-lasting
pain control without risk um we make a
statement that no no physicians should
start further patients on these
medications uh with the goal of being on
them long term
they've never said that not in 2010 not
in 2015 not in 2020 if you look at what
the statements of medical organizations
typically do is they they trump access
to treatment right
that means they would like to do their
best to solve it but in a way of solving
it that still allows them to
sell more health care
um
so you've never heard had them call out
you know the science on on the pain
medicine saying look this was not good
science we didn't we shouldn't have been
doing this um and in that sense i do not
think they're they're
uh uh their voice is uncompromised they
they are protecting their financial
relationships yeah i just pulled up cdc
foundation you talk about pfizer
uh you know all the main ones gates
foundation i think even j and j a lot of
these guys are also backing those guys
up you know what what makes it difficult
when someone like you comes up and
you're sharing these things
uh the the tough part becomes who do you
trust
do you sit there and trust these
independent organizations that are
supposed to
do what's best for us yet behind closed
doors they're being funded by
these big corporations that can like you
said if somebody gives you money how
hard is it to say no to it right it's
not a lot of statesmen left around
nowadays it's just who funded me and let
me be loyal to them because if i don't
get reelected how am i going to get this
money to get reelected i need their
support to help me out who do people
trust
and i don't even maybe i said in my ted
talk too but like there's lots of
studies showing that it doesn't take
much to change a doctor's prescribing
you know about a 20 lunch is all it
takes um i think there was a journal the
american medical center study yeah
twenty dollars
for a lunch is all it takes
um
and in 2019 the journal medical
association published a study these guys
looked county by county
where where where where there was more
frequent gifts to doctors
by pharmaceutical companies there was
increased opioid prescribing and
increased opioid death
it's tough to read
okay because i've been able to practice
medicine my entire career without
without accepting any gifts
you know in the securities industry but
i would say okay i would i would say
that it's it's
you you want you
peop there are good people in medicine
there are ethical people in medicine but
what i say and that when i give my talks
i try to remind it's very often what you
have are good people in systems where
they're they have bad incentives they
have incentives not to do the right
thing
very good point so good people with bad
incentives so the compensation structure
is set up in a way where they're tempted
to do
the wrong thing and to be influenced by
it that's a scary thought you know
this is you saw that in wells fargo like
they i totally get it i totally get it i
mean yeah of course with the credit card
i totally get the whole i don't know
what the number was it was a ludicrous
amount but you know one thing they did
in the financial industry again i'm
giving you this stuff that maybe you
know you you
if you're in this world you can bring it
up to others if i'm securities license
you know what my limit is for gifts
i can't give you i can't get you a gift
more than a hundred dollars per year
so i'm limited right what if they put a
gift limited to doctors
what if you can't give them gifts
what if it can't come with that now i
know the sales part is kind of taken out
but you are dealing with someone's
health and life
so should there be an incentive to get
the i don't know
i think it's a different story when i'm
dealing with investments versus
someone's health i don't know if i'm
comfortable for the doctor to get a gift
by a pharmaceutical salesman it's kind
of weird i don't know well there i mean
there are limits to gifts but but
understand
there's it's a very sneaky history about
what then compromise consists a gift
okay and you can start to have you can
bend the rules okay
so say you're not giving this doctor a
gift
you're paying them to teach
and
all of a sudden these paid speaking gigs
constitute teaching they're not gifts
but for there for a couple thousand
dollars yeah and you might remember the
case of insist pharmaceuticals that is
insys
and they were found to have a sham
teaching or a speaking program
where the people on the on the speaking
program were high prescribers and they
got paid to give these quote unquote
talks often with only their office staff
and they would get paid so while there
are gifts and uh there there is the
physician payment sunshine act where you
can go look it up and there's limits
you can sort of get around this and say
like okay we're this is technically
teaching or this is some other service
that is not a gift but it's com you know
we compensate for that yeah you know you
have
you know this is also true in the device
industry where you'll have
orthopedic surgeons on the boards of
device companies with a new artificial
hip and then that surgeon puts in that
particular hip um
so you you have it when when there is
you can have these conflicts of interest
in a number of ways that circum
circumnavigates the definition of a gift
but yeah that's an ongoing issue
yeah i mean if
if this is what you study and this is
what you talk about
and there still isn't anybody in power
that is willing to talk about this and
bring it up
i've never heard it i've never heard
anybody get up and uh as a politician a
governor a president a candidate vietnam
we have to fix the opioid crisis okay
how what do we do
uh so what can we do at this point you
mentioned the four things right what can
we do at this point to
uh address this well on it on a
individual level or individual patient
level okay i would want anyone who
watches this talk watches you um watches
anyone okay understand that
the data is a is convincing okay we've
done we now have we should have done the
study 25 years ago and we didn't but
we've done it recently in 2018 we've
done a blinded trial to see do opioids
work after a year and they don't
that that was the space trial s-p-a-c-e
so for someone you know who's got back
pain joint pain
understand that
they should not be taking opioids with
the intention of ongoing treatment and
therefore they can protect themselves
okay i would also let them know that
don't even take it for two months or
even one month your risk of becoming
dependent goes extremely goes up to like
one-third
so if you're going to take these
medicines say for like
you've got a you know a broken bone
kidney stone
absolutely you can take them then but
you with the goal of being off of them
quickly you take it for like a week
maybe two if it's bad okay
but the goal is to get off of them
what you also need to do in the
immediate term here is um
is find a worse you know compassionate
treatment for those who
probably through no fault of their own
started these medications we're told
they weren't nearly as dangerous as we
thought and became dependent and now
we're addicted and and now they are
using we need to find ways to get them
the treatment they need not you know
not because it's going to cure them but
we're trying to minimize the risk of
damage and give them as long and happy
life as possible and that's through
things like addiction services addiction
treatment medical assisted therapy um
those are the things we can do on an
individual level and we can do as a on a
medical level
i still want to reform a political
system that
caters to the business interests of
medicine um
i was hoping for like congressional i
was i was ready to go i'll go to
congress and talk to them like they did
for the mortgage-backed securities
crisis
why haven't you yet they haven't had
they have not had those hearings on the
opioid crisis i would absolutely have
gone
um
what's the process for you to
recommend it what's the process for you
to get enough signatures what's the
process for you to get
enough people to say because listen
seventy 000 people died in 2020 based on
the stat right
that's 70 000 people's brother sister
cousin daughter son mom dad best friend
in one year in one year we're talking
about right and no one's even talking
about it if that's a stat how many
signatures do you need to get on the
congressional to be able to talk about
this stuff because when i watch your ted
talks you know what's the first thing i
ask myself here's the first thing i
asked myself
i said this thing's got 45 000 views
what yeah that's nothing it's a
two-year-old video how the hell does
this thing only have 40 45 000 views is
not going to make an impact so what do
you need to do to get in front of
congressional to get enough people's
attention to say hey we kind of want to
see what the congress wants to do about
this
um
i have had relationships with with with
a congress uh with congress members uh
you know klobuchar i've spoken with her
i spoke with angie craig and given talks
about this um
i i don't i don't have
i can't say i have the voice to sort of
just call their office and say let's
have a meeting i i don't i don't have
that kind of have you tried that i have
how many people um
my local representatives i think you got
to go more than that i think you got to
play a little bit of offense maybe go
buy a sales book
and
make the phone call send the emails
because i think this is that important
thing that if you've done research on it
you have way more credibility than a guy
like me to go and talk about this i just
have pain in my heart because the person
i lost i love deirdre like i love that i
miss that person i lost that person
because of this and it should
never happen so uh i i don't have your
kind of influence uh in regards i don't
have the doctor in front of my name
this is your world that you're studying
i think i would encourage you i'm a
nobody to encourage you to do this
you're living in your own world you have
your own family things that you're doing
i would encourage you
to uh play a little bit more often to
bring this up by the way have you
reached out to both sides of the aisle
it sounds like it's only democrats
you're reaching out to
oh but those are the ones in minnesota
that are local okay
maybe reach out to the other side maybe
somebody on the other side maybe reach
out to if mccain was talking about this
maybe reach out to his daughter maybe
reach out to
i think if you play the laws of numbers
and say can you watch this please call
me i have some stats i want to share
with you i think someone's going to say
yes
i'm just saying if this is
i i
i am not i am not i don't have business
training i don't have media relations
training i don't all i know is my word
like this is what i'm seeing here's why
it's happening and i've got data to back
it up but i think that i don't i don't
have i can't say that i have the
i haven't been trained on the skill set
though to get that message out there
more effectively and i i am open to any
and all
in terms of how does one how does one go
about promotion of that and get an
audience that's absolutely what i'd be
interested in you got a great story you
got you got something you're talking
about that
uh if 70 million died just last year 70
000. you're above 70 i'm sorry my
probably seventy thousand died last year
fifty thousand a year before let's say
it's four hundred thousand a thousand
people in the last eight years okay
let's just put that number give or take
right four hundred thousand
the individual that dies how many people
do they have that love them
that's dear friends or family to them
let's just say
eight per 400 thousand that's 3.2
million people you got millions of
people that are interested in this kind
of being heard by the people at the top
and if i ask you a question i say who's
the most powerful person that's talking
about this
you couldn't even come up with one name
10 seconds you were stuttering because
you couldn't think of somebody i think
there's millions of people that would
like to see
this be more of an important uh subject
to be talked about maybe team up with
somebody that's a good marketer good on
social media good on the emails good on
contact and good in sales and see if
that person can help you get in front of
those guys but i think you're i mean
we're doing our part this is our
platform your message is going to be out
there and god knows how many people are
going to reach out to you because
they're going to say i heard the message
i'd love to help but on top of that i
think there'd be other people that you
can play
offense with to get in front of the
right people well i'm all i'm all for uh
in increasing the urgency behind this uh
obviously
well
i mean covet has you know they've been
almost 700 000 okay in the last year and
a half so i mean it has basically
you know it has taken the public health
spotlight obviously but this other
problem has not gone away but that's why
i can't say do i know what drugs are
who's working on this right now because
all the public health resources right
now have been dedicated to covid you
made understandably so but there's this
other urgent need that hasn't gone away
and i'm
absolutely uh prepared to do all the
work that i need to do i'm ready to do
it
yeah i mean listen the the world can
handle
america can handle multiple different
crises at the same time and you and you
mentioned like three points i i i think
if you went into a lecture hall and
and you you asked them to raise their
hand who do you know a close friend or a
family member half of course half i
believe you i believe you that's why i
think that's why i think this has
this needs to get to the next level
anyways by the way if somebody wants to
get a hold of you how can they find you
um i don't know if you can put up on
your uh i'm gonna put it below don't
worry about it so here's what we'll do
if it's a website you can tell us what
we're also gonna put in the description
go right ahead um
endtheopioidcrisis.com is my website
um
that is e-n-d-t-h-e opioidcrisis.com
uh i don't know if you put a gmail email
on there or is that sort of there's
rules are you gonna
contact me through the website um
uh you can find me on linkedin as well
uh dr chris
i will send you all of that give us all
that information we're going to put all
of it below because if anybody is
watching this and you were directly
affected by this and you can have an
impact where he can get in front of
congress and give this message and other
people can participate i'll go to other
states i'll talk to their legislator
absolutely please reach out to dr chris
johnson
uh dr chris johnson thank you for making
the time and being willing to take the
questions i just threw your way and
addressing them to the best of abilities
i think you have a message that needs to
be heard and i think a lot of people are
hoping this thing gets heard by the
right people thank you for making the
time for being guest on valuetainment i
appreciate that thank you so much for
inviting me i hope people are
moved by it
i think they will be just out of
curiosity do you have anybody close to
your friend or family that also got
addicted to opioids that you lost
because they couldn't stop using them
comment well i'm actually curious to
hear your stories and also thoughts on
what he had to say and if you know if
you know somebody on a way to get him in
front of those guys let's figure out a
way contact him all those informations
below but if you enjoyed this interview
i did an interview also with dr jason
fong where he had different angle he's a
he has a treatment for obesity cancer
diabetes very interesting guy that i
spoke to he's another guy that's got
millions of views if you've never
watched this you'll get a different
angle
from what he has to say i think you'll
enjoy that interview as well take care
everybody bye
[Music]